Prometheus is a movie that in only a few
short days of release has caused debate
amongst film nerds widespread arguments
and more confusion than any film
released in years many complain of
unanswered questions poor writing or
even that it's just plain boring having
seen the film multiple times now I feel
I've come into an understanding of the
events that take place in the movie this
video is not meant to be seen as fact
since many things in this movie are open
to interpretation this is just my take
on the film and hopefully it can help
let's start with the title prometheus
what is Prometheus well in the movie
it's the name of the ship that carries
the crew which are on a journey to meet
the beings they hope created humans but
what is Prometheus to literature in
Greek mythology Prometheus was a Titan
who is known as the creator of mankind
and also for the theft of fire for human
use which helped further the progression
of humankind Prometheus was then
punished by Zeus and sentenced to
eternal torment for his sin also
prometheus is known as a figure who
represented the search for scientific
knowledge thus the name of the ship in
the film Prometheus was also known as
foreshadowing the fact that efforts to
improve human life could bring forth
tragedy instead that brings me to the
opening of the film the movie opens with
grand shots of a desolate earth no
life-forms are shown anywhere except
this dude in a cloak walking around and
a UFO above him this creature then
ingests this black liquid which degrades
his body scattering his ashes into the
ocean
his sacrifice seems to then spring forth
the building blocks of human life to me
this creature embodies the myth of
Prometheus the mythological creator of
mankind and the character in Greek
mythology who helped further human
civilization but the question is why did
the engineers as these beings are
eventually called knowingly create life
did they create life for a purpose we'll
get to that later
next we meet our two main characters in
the film Shaw and Holloway played by
Noomi Rapace and the dude who looks like
Tom Hardy who isn't as good as Tom
already and it's kind of crappiest part
of the movie nevertheless they discover
this ancient hieroglyphic thing of a
dude pointing to a system of planets and
it's the same type of painting and
design that they found around the entire
world this leads to a team of people and
working on the prometheus to find the
creators of mankind next we meet one of
the film's most important characters
David and Android played by Michael
Fassbender we see David performing his
daily routines which consists of
learning new languages watching classic
movies and spying on people's dreams he
decides to take a look at Elizabeth
Shaw's mind while she sleeps and for me
this told me two things the obvious one
would be that we learn a little bit
about Shaw's past she got a good father
a religious upbringing and a belief in
God
the second was much more important we
discover that David is curious he's an
independent thinker and he does what he
wants to do why would he peer into
Shaw's dreams what purpose or benefit
would that bring to a robot
the only reason can be that he wanted to
know more about her he wanted to fulfill
a desire inside him to learn about
something new with no regard for how
personal or intrusive he was being this
is very important to the movie and helps
bring understanding to the things David
does throughout the film eventually all
the characters awake from sleep and land
on LV 2 to 3 discovering what appear to
be objects made by someone now let me
reiterate they land on LV 2 to 3 not
lv-426 where the original alien takes
place the team explores the inside of
this structure discovering a large
human-like face made out of stone a room
filled with containers that have some
sort of black goo oozing out of it and
worms those worms are important we'll
get to those later continuing his course
of independent curiosity David takes one
of these containers with him keeping
that a secret from everyone else also
during this scene the Explorers alter
the state of this room's environment
causing the black goo to eventually leak
from the container they also discover a
dead engineer body left behind
decapitated by the door that leads to
the giant stone head and the two idiot
team members who are just stupid get
left behind in our total they'll be
picked up the following morning due to
bad weather outside the ship now let's
jump to a little exchange between the
captain and vicars the captain jokingly
hints at Vickers being a robot leading
her inviting him into her room for
implied
sex it's never clear whether or not they
go through with it
as it's never discussed or referenced
again but this has led people to
question is Vickers a robot well there
are two different schools of thought to
this let's start with the evidence
suggesting that she is human she sleeps
in a cryo chamber in the beginning of
the film which an Android wouldn't need
we see her doing push-ups after
awakening from sleep like she's working
off some kind of cryo hangover she
demonstrates emotions such as anger and
shock and she seems to be fatigued
throughout some of the more physical
scenes in the movie she seems jealous
when Weyland says David is like a son to
him as we later hear in the film Vickers
calls Weyland father and we hear that
they constantly argued over the
ownership of the whelen company all
human traits then there is evidence
supporting the robot theory as stated
she refers to Weyland as her father
while he seemed too old to be David the
Android also refers to Weyland as a
parent Vickers is also able to throw
David against a wall and keep him pinned
there as seen in previous films dim
androids be strong later we learned at
the surgery module in her quarters only
performs procedures on males
it's not even calibrated for females
which would be odd considering it's use
is for vicars when Weyland later dies in
the film she shows little to no emotion
which could suggest a deep hatred for
her father or that she's an Android also
I brought up that Vickers slept in a
cryo chamber a human trait as a robot
would need the assistance of cryo sleep
however in the first alien film Ashe
slept in one as he was hiding the fact
that he was an Android from the crew
there are also people who believe it's
possible that Vickers isn't aware that
she is an Android and that she's lived
her whole life thinking she was a human
I find this hard to believe simply
because she must have cut herself at
least a few times noticing that her
blood looks like milk would be a pretty
big hint to me huh but perhaps the most
important evidence suggesting that there
is another Android on board the
prometheus besides David is this
robots there is a rumor about this movie
that there is a robot in prometheus that
maybe - when the filmmaker himself says
something like that you have to wonder
it's clear that he was being very
careful not to give defining evidence to
either theory
she never bleeds once in the film if we
saw that we'd know so what do you
believe is the vicar's in Android now in
the scene where Vickers pins David to a
wall
David reveals that the sleeping Weyland
told him to try harder this seems to
suggest that Weyland is instructing
David and possibly Vickers on some
course of action perhaps treating the
rest of the crew as expendable to
fulfill his desires in the very next
scene while Shaw discovers that the
engineers DNA matched human DNA we see
David examining the capsule he brought
back in which he gazes at a tiny speck
of the black goo david wastes no time
and immediately goes to dr. Holloway's
spiking his drink with the alien
specimen but while that is important the
conversation these two characters have
is perhaps the most pivotal conversation
in the entire film Holloway says he is
disappointed because all the engineers
were dead and his whole goal was to hope
to ask them the big question why were
humans made for what purpose did they
make us
this leads David to respond why do you
think your people made me yeah we made
you cuz we could can you imagine how
disappointing it would be for you to
hear the same thing from your Creator oh
and you suck at acting it's quite
possible that the engineers did not have
some profound reason for creating us
they didn't need to have some grand
purpose perhaps they just created humans
because they could we'll talk more about
this later now we get to see the two
lost freaking dumb scientist exploring
more of the caverns and they discover a
huge pile of dead engineers literally
stacked one on top of the other against
a wall one of them says it
like a scene out of a holocaust painting
it seems obvious that this pile of dead
engineers and the previously discovered
decapitated one suggest that a battle of
some kind took place there possibly even
amongst their own kind exterminating one
another more on that later in the next
scene we learn a little more about Shaw
she apparently is unable to bear
children and in an attempt to make her
feel better
Holloway bangs her hey sometimes it just
works that way I can't have children
let's have sex but I can't make babies
yes but what's important about this
scene is a question that shot asks when
Holloway suggests that she should stop
believing in God because the engineers
made us she responds and who made them
now we get an important scene that was
possibly handled a little too cliche the
two lost scientists the stupid idiots
are back in this room with a stone head
and the black goo has now created tiny
streams along the ground
remember those worms we saw earlier well
they're back but they're different now
they're not only much larger and
aggressive but their genetics and look
have drastically changed affected by the
black gooey stuff Vasili retarded
scientist tries touching the dang thing
which to me was a pretty friggin stupid
thing for him to do it wraps itself
around his arm breaking it and when the
other scientist cuts off its head it
grows right back a definite trait of
worms the same time the other scientist
is sprayed with a black goo which gets
inside his helmet now Holloway wakes up
and in just an overnight period he sees
that he's been infected with something
and we know that it's from David spiking
his punch as the team heads back to the
caverns to search for the missing
scientist David is able to convince the
captain to allow him to go off on his
own to fix a malfunctioning probe David
uses this to his advantage and discovers
an engineer still in cryosleep and an
entire navigation system pointing to
earth showing that the engineers planned
on traveling to earth but something
stopped the process
meanwhile Holloway gets worse and worse
to the point where Vickers doesn't want
to let him get back on the ship for fear
of infecting the whole crew with this
intense herpes he seems to have he
willingly gives himself up and Vickers
uses the flamethrower on him it is
reasonable to assume that whatever
happened to those worms would have
happened to Holloway
he may have retained much of his human
self but he would have been mutated and
violent turned into some form of a
weapon now when David is alone with Shaw
he discovers that she is knocked up but
not just knocked up she's three months
pregnant with an abnormal fetus not only
is this impossible because she's barren
but they only just had sex the previous
night upon learning that the fetus as
alien she decides to do anything and
everything to get it out of her leading
to one of the film's best scenes she
uses Vickers medical pod and induces
surgery on herself removing the creature
from its side of her which we will later
learn is the very first facehugger ever
form in its earlier stages of
development remember the dude who got
sprayed with a black goo well he returns
wreaking havoc on everything in sight
it's fair to assume that this is what
would have happened to Holloway if he
hadn't given himself over to the flames
though so what do we know about this
black goo now whatever it comes in
contact with retains the basic structure
and abilities of its genetic makeup as
seen by the worm regrowing its head and
the scientists still appearing to be
human but it makes its host stronger and
most of all violent and destructive with
no shade of its former self quite a
weapon these engineers have manufactured
Shaw staggers into a room discovering
that Weyland is in fact alive hoping
himself to meet his makers with the goal
of seeing if they can lengthen his life
and save him from death upon first
viewing of the film this twist bothered
me it didn't really seem to have a point
and it felt like it wasn't necessary to
the story but after my second viewing it
didn't bother me as much I realized it
helped bring more light to David's
actions and why he seemed to have his
own agenda with things it is very
reasonable to assume much of what David
did was under orders from Whalen later
the captain is talking with Shaw and he
reveals he thinks that what they're on
is actually a military base he says
they're not
stupid enough to make weapons of mass
destruction on their own doorstep it got
out it turned on him
it seemed a little far-fetched to
believe that he could figure that out so
quickly but I think that character is
clearly much smarter than he lets on
he's actually one of my favorite
characters in the whole movie neither
subtle but plays him really well is it
possible that these engineers were
infected with their own creation causing
an inner war amongst themselves does
that explain the piles of bodies
discovered earlier the captain says
he'll do whatever he has to to see that
that black death Gustav doesn't get back
to earth now we cut to Shaw David and
Weyland and some other pointless
characters going to awake the last
remaining engineer David reveals he
discovered that the engineers were in
the process of leaving for Earth when
Shaw asks why he says sometimes in order
to create one must first destroy after
they awake the engineer David says
something to him who knows what he says
we don't really know it did kind of
remind me of that language he was
practicing in the beginning of the film
perhaps someone will find out what it is
later I don't know whatever he says the
engineer doesn't like it he rips off
David's head and kills everyone in the
room except Shaw who escapes she gets
message to the captain that they must
destroy the ship because the engineer is
planning on continuing his original
mission heading to earth destroying it
with what it first seemed like a
surprising amount of acceptance of his
death
the captain flies Prometheus into the
derelict stopping the ship from
continuing its course but I recalled
later that the captain said he'd do
anything to keep the earth safe so I
bought it
Vickers gets to the escape pod only to
be crushed by falling debris Oh too bad
now Shaw goes back to the remains of the
Prometheus ship which is Vickers
separate pod ejected by the captain in
it she discovers her alien fetus is
still alive and it's grown to a very
large size through her earpiece she
hears that David is still functional and
he warns her that the engineer is very
angry and is coming for her she lets
loose the giant facehugger which
overpowers the engineer and Plan
a tentacle in his mouth Shaw then goes
back finds David's head and body and
convinces him to take her on one of the
remaining derelict ships searching for
who made the engineers now we get the
scene we see the body of the engineer
shaking violently and something bursts
out of it it's the very first xenomorph
alien and it's early stages of
development
it's shrieks revealing a second set of
Jaws and then the screen goes black so
what the f does all this mean
well here's my take the engineers
created humans as seen in the very first
scene of the movie why do they really
need a reason as revealed when David is
told by Holloway the only reason humans
created AI was because they could it
doesn't have to be a profound reason the
engineers created us so why along the
way did they decide to destroy us and
what stopped them I have a couple
theories perhaps they were dissatisfied
with the course humans took with all of
the death and destruction that humans
have brought or perhaps there were
always two classes of engineers some who
believed humans were a great creation
and some who wanted us dead
perhaps this led to a war amongst
themselves where they turned on each
other killing themselves off whatever
the reason it's clear they wanted us
dead in the end why well the answer
isn't entirely clear in the film many
have been angered by that I'll tell you
why it doesn't bother me for one there's
been a sequel for Prometheus planned
since the start of production on this
film it would be absurd and downright
ludicrous for us to expect all the
answers in this movie but also I think
some of the best science fiction films
are the ones that ask the big questions
movies that present the audience was
something that is difficult to
understand and perhaps never gives us
the full answers early reviews of
Prometheus are mostly positive but
slightly mixed this isn't surprising to
me considering the original
alien film also received the same
reception upon its initial release
according to Wikipedia critical reaction
to the film was initially mixed reviews
by variety sight and sound Vincent Canby
and even Leonard Maltin
mixed or negative a review by Time Out
said the film was an empty bag of tricks
whose production values and expensive
trickery cannot disguise imaginative
poverty which brings me to something
alien one of the largest complaints I've
heard of Prometheus is that it leaves us
too many unanswered questions some have
even gone as far as to blame that encore
writing but just for one second remove
yourself from aliens alien 3 Alien
Resurrection and the AVP movies remove
yourself from all the lore and books
associated with alien imagine that you
are a person in 1979 sitting down to
watch alien for the first time when the
film ends you may have thought okay that
was scary but what's with that giant
creature attached to that gun thingy
what are those weird spider things that
lay eggs in people's throats and why did
that random ship crash into the planet
and what are those eggs doing inside of
it and who sent the distress signal to
get them there in the first place
alien has just as many unanswered
questions as Prometheus does if not even
more it's just that now over 30 years
later the film is so famous that people
tend to overlook them we live in an
Internet world where people are so used
to immediate answers and satisfaction
that it seems like we've forgotten how
great it is to see a film that asks us
questions the audience a film that makes
us question things and wonder and search
not every film needs a concrete answer
to every question it poses to leave us
guessing and wanting more is a bold
choice on the filmmakers part it's my
firm belief that years from now
Prometheus will be hailed as a wholly
original science fiction film and ranked
in with other sci-fi classics that
helped mold the genre
[Music]